okay there's a lot to unpack here
15 million merits black mirror season 1
episode 2 and spoiler warning I'm diving
right into this this episode 7 years old
and if you care you should have seen it
by now
so um boy it's it is hard to know where
to start with this one this is dealing
with a lot of stuff which has been sort
of a sticking point for me previously
like the the episode of Archangel I
criticized for having a couple of
elements and not seeming to know what
its central one was and sort of the I
didn't feel like it juggle things very
well so I do want to clarify that in
this point how many things are going on
and feeding into the story actually
doesn't work for me
I think I think the various things just
feed into each other better and more
cleanly than they did for arcade or
whereas Archangel they were similar
tangental but narrative ly they didn't
quite build on each other here I feel
like all the different elements do and I
mean I you know just trying to parse it
out in my head I'll probably even miss
stuff but you know things from the the
drudgery of a workday to the
artificiality of existence to putting
value on stuff that isn't even physical
and real but still tempting you to spend
your money on it to literally have to
give up something for anything even the
ability to to just skip being advertised
at you know the the claim of here's this
here's this dream you could achieve the
at the end holy crap the the the
co-opting of revolution and anger by the
corporate entities that it was
originally directed at who go I like
your spirit I'll pay you to do that and
that it works and yeah
that free it happens there oh boy
so let's okay let's start with the
performances so I'm probably gonna
butcher his last name but I'm gonna try
Daniel Kaluga who I of course know from
get out which was my favorite movie of
last year and he's up for an Oscar so
fingers crossed for that he is he's
really good on this and I suspected
watching this I'm like I bet Jordan
Peele saw his saw his performance in
this and it's a big part of why he got
cast and get out and I checked and yes
it is this guy does intense really well
and I I it's it's difficult sometimes to
really put into words how hard that is
because often times you know actors
trying to be intense just get louder or
you know just triangle bug-eyed or they
or they it just feels like an
affectation it doesn't feel like genuine
like intensity where I'm watching him
and I feel like I can I'm seeing his
heart rate increase like just watching
him he he does that so well and yeah I
mean even before that he sells it really
well it the whole initial sort of plot
hinges on something that usually bothers
me which is this kind of I don't want to
say love at first sight because I find
it to be kind of belittling to the
concept of love but infatuation at first
sight which is an inciting incident in a
heck of a lot of stories TVs movies
books what-have-you
and as a rule of thumb I really don't
like it it actually works for me here
largely again as has frequently been the
case with Black Mirror because of really
smart writing because just that line
that Bing has just saying you know this
is the first real thing I've experienced
and you know with how artificial and
confined the world that he lives in is I
actually couldn't believe that this one
tiny tenuous thread of a connection that
he feels to someone he's got to cling to
and go all in on because he's feeling
something that he doesn't feel otherwise
so I actually buy it in this whereas
usually these sorts of setups I wouldn't
buy it I I thought there was gonna be a
twist reveal as to sort of the nature of
the world I was expecting something like
either she or he or somebody was gonna
like win the contest and find out no
there is no better life there is no
outside world it's really all just this
I'm go kind of the running man twist if
you know that movie boy that's an old
enough movie that I can't count on
people catching that reference anymore
in any case I was expecting something
along those lines so the fact that it
doesn't really go there at all and
instead just keeps it insular on this
society that is is powered by people and
then drip feeds them just enough to keep
them going literally spinning their
wheels and it just goes all in on that
zeroes in on that that that was really
interesting I mean I started to I think
the point at which I realized I don't
know where this is going was when he
knuckle down to get that 15 million
again he's watching the thing fade on
his hand
he's just worked in working working
working and then as soon as he hits 15
million doesn't even go over it stops
dead gets himself a ticket I'm like I
don't know where he's going with this
and when he broke out the the the shard
of glass initially I was like he's gonna
he's gonna attack the judges but he
didn't and again the the intensity of
the delivery of that was it was
monumental I mean really the the amount
of anger and rage and frustration and
how real it felt I mean this truly felt
like somebody lashing out at a world
that he couldn't stand and then that
quiet moment of the guy offering him to
let him do that professionally and he
does he does the live stream of the
thing
held to his neck twice a week and like I
said it's the co-opting of rebellion
because it's cool and it sells and well
in the real world money but in the
context of this episode you know the
opportunity for something better than
you have is is a massive temptation you
lose your passion to break the system
when the system does right by you so
even if you came up knowing how the
system breaks people having watched it
firsthand
having been deeply directly affected by
it if you have a chance to be at the top
that's really hard to turn down and most
people can't and even he despite how
pure his anger and his rage was he still
can do it which i think is very human
and I like the very melancholy note of
him in his room just looking out at the
forest and not making it clear his state
of mind anymore he's kind of inscrutable
which I which I appreciate and I enjoy I
think it would have undercut things like
to like have a tear go down or like be
really clear that oh he's just as
miserable here as those with no we don't
know if he is maybe he is maybe he's
genuinely happier maybe right now he's
happier maybe you won't be later who
knows yeah that's all interpretable and
i think that was a really good call if I
had a complaint it's not a problem with
the narrative it's more like just
something that I just take issue with as
a general thing I take frustration with
the feeding in of the stereotype of sex
workers as being drugged out and coerced
and I don't want to dive into this too
deeply but I mean and
and by no means am I saying that that
never happens in various sects work
because it certainly does but it's it's
also the the reigning stereotype that if
someone is doing it it could only
possibly be because they were coerced or
drugged or both it's just a stereotype
that I've I've gotten frustrated because
it's almost exclusively the stereotype
of anyone who's involved in that kind of
work on any level is either a scumbag or
a victim and I mean that that's just
frustrating for me but at the same time
as much as that is kind of a item for me
personally I will also acknowledge that
for the purposes of this story and what
the narrative is doing it does make
sense and it is justified so I'm not
actually upset with the show for doing
that it's more like a reminder of my
frustration with the fact that that is
almost the completely entirely certainly
the prevalent if not the entirety of how
sex work gets portrayed in popular
culture and that's that's just something
that frustrates me in general not this
shows fault but really that's kind of
the only thing that I could possibly
complain about this with and that's
again not a problem with the episode
that's that's my baggage so yeah 15
million merits like I said there's a lot
going on here and for how much there is
going on it really is marvelously
balanced and I think we get just the
right dosage of seeing the other people
there or how they react or respond to
this world that they live in whether
they seem to be longing for more whether
they are just apathetic to it whether
they have completely bought into it and
we get those those layers we get those
levels and it just it this is a real
complete package of a story do you just
you feel like not knowing you know how
exactly the world became this it makes
total self-contained sense regardless of
the specifics of how we got here it's
not as insanely far-fetched
if you're willing to be metaphorical
with it in terms of the whole you know
spinning your wheels to make credit to
buy things that you don't need so this
was uh this was this is a point of one
this is this is what this was uh this
one was sharp this wasn't this one
wasn't so much necessarily at least for
me about that sort of sinking oh my god
that I sometimes get from Black Mirror
but this this was um this is the one
that I I would label most appropriately
as satire as you know pointed satirical
commentary as opposed to just sort of
extrapolation into a horrific
possibility and you've really well done
so Black Mirror 15 million merits what
were your thoughts on this one well
whatever they were drop something down
in the comments let's talk about it do
all that stuff you know what it is likes
and subscribes and Twitter followers and
patreon support maybe you know options
there links for all that stuff's down
below and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
you